[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
ah
otra cosa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
somos una banda
que de amor no sabe mucho nos enamoramos
fácil eso sí
sobre el amor no no podemos hablar mucho
porque hoy tenemos justo soy argentino
se nota y lo sigo analizamos todo el
tiempo
y tenemos ahí un pequeño resquemor de
esta gente amaros tenemos hablar de amor
bueno somos potatoes fechas van una
banda que practica música muy antigua
años 20 años 30 1920 1930
vamos a hacer a un tema que es un
poquito más antiguo antes de 1900 es un
rap que compuso un hombre antes no había
whatsapp internet todas esas cosas no
existían en 1900 y este hombre vendió en
aquel entonces más de un millón de
copias de esta apertura de este tema que
haremos sabré
bueno
[Música]
i
jajaja
a
[Música]
d
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
por qué
[Música]
pero
y bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno tengo que sigue lo vamos a tocar
porque nos recuerdan mucho
una torsión que hicimos en cádiz también
en jimena de la frontera fue estaba él
se han llegado no sabía que no hablaba
en inglés entonces intenté que toda la
gente cantara este tema que se llama my
para qué alimento
la letra es muy fácil pero no sabía en
inglés
entonces en lugar de cantar más claras
del limite cantaron me gustan los
caracoles
era de esperar
al año siguiente vamos a tocar un
festival a birmingham
y dijimos por qué no ser al revés el
número de que canten maybach que siga
las voley que canten me gustan los
caracoles la noche emblemático para
nosotros porque porque pasan dos cosas
lindas vendimos muchos discos casi 6.300
pasajeros 6200
treinta y tantos a ver si duplicamos esa
cifra y también logramos que la gente
cantara era muy gracioso de todas
maneras allí imagínense me gustan las
caracolas
y ese tipo de cosas vamos a intentar de
que lo canten es fácil es muy simple es
eso me gustan los caracoles me gustan
los caracoles me gustan los caracoles y
al final lo más bonito que hay vamos a
ponernos las manos así como si nos
pudiéramos quitando un pelito si en la
comisura derecha de los labios y vamos a
hacer
ok con cada uno como puede como sepa
esto no es la parte de ridícula lo
ridículo viene antes
que debemos decir los quiero chupar
ok hay un poco de luz de sala así que
vemos las caras
puede ser efe
déjala dejarla despeja la luz y no
podemos soportar
o no
[Música]
entonces
ah
[Música]
no no
para tratar amor
o
las caracolas
gustan los castores
están dos caras
[Música]
los actores
los quiero
[Música]
y
bien
[Música]
e
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
están los caracoles
me gustan los caracoles
los quiero
[Música]
i
sí
d
[Aplausos]
no solo hacen de la palma
lo más importante
[Música]
bueno
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias que vienen cantáis
bueno
el amor y el desamor
no voy a hablar más porque no preparamos
nada
meto mentir a la música no resulta que
tenemos a los hermanos son gemelos de
madres distintas eso no mi hermano los
hermanos pinzón
venimos desde la furgoneta nosotros
hacemos terapia de grupo como
imaginaréis argentino punto cero
antólogo psicólogo o comercial
comercial es lo que hago aquí y también
si canalizamos
vienen peleados desde hoy desde la
furgoneta
porque mamá no sé que el amor de mamá no
sé cuánto el amor género esta disputa
entonces porque siempre lo cuidara de
las vastas
el tema que sigue se llama royal garden
blues de los señores lo permiten
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no
en televisión
[Música]
no no
pero la vida
[Música]
en este listado
se esperan para ver aún pero espero
encontrar yo me da colaboró parece que
están seis textos los 20 estados
[Música]
no no no
la gruta
caracas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
puede ser que la versión
la muerte
no sé
[Música]
i
señores señoras muchas gracias por venir
nos vamos a ir gracias por quedarse
antes del café y nos vamos tenemos todo
este tipo de cosas modernas que usáis
vosotros y sé que msn baxter paloma
mensajera
no tenemos instagram facebook y demás y
demás y demás también
nos vamos gracias por invitarnos látex
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mejor
[Música]
bueno
owen
fuentes
hola me encanta
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cómo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
[Música]
por qué
[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagina